this is the capital of capital this is
growing faster than any of those
jurisdictions any of them what you
really look for as an investor is in
growth I mean the way you make money
when you invest is to invest in growth
opportunities you know New York's a very
important Market uh London Hong Kong has
issues around China now which not
everybody loves uh but Abu Dhabi has
none of those it and it has growth if I
had to buy an index today in other words
the way to measure this as an investor
if you had a choice which index would
you want to own for the next 5 years it
would be Abu Dhabi not any of the others
cuz there there's no way they're going
to grow this fast mhm